there's all this covid vaccine news
and um this is one of the latest stories
it got a lot of attention here
recently nine great apes were vaccinated
against kovid at the san diego zoo
yeah now these covid vaccinated animals
got a lot of attention
and that's led to this new message from
the california department of
public health take a look
many californians have complained about
difficulty and delays in obtaining a
coveted vaccine appointment
nowhere has this frustration been more
apparent than with our vaccinate all
california animals program
while many people applauded the gorillas
that were recently vaccinated for covid
at the san diego zoo
not all animals can navigate
california's complex
online vaccine appointment websites like
the great apes
so creatures like dogs cats birds and
garden snails
are being left out in the cold without a
shot
it's also been revealed that several of
the gorillas cut in line at the flamingo
oasis vaccination site
while two other primates received shots
after donating their feces
to florida governor ron desantis's
campaign fund
rest assured the california department
of public health
is working hard to eliminate these
inequities so that
all animals can receive protection from
covid and we can move on to vaccinate
trees
shrubs and abandoned car tires until
finally we can move on to people
aged 16 to 64. without underlying
medical conditions
until then continue to mask up
and blah blah blah brought to you by
the california department of public
health we're as confused as you are
that's unbelievable i have not had my
shot yet but i'm waiting for a snail
to get vaccinated is that right well
it's essential personnel first
yeah well i like snails yeah snails get
the job done
oh wait here comes your covert vaccine
listen to that the walls in this theater
are paper thin
you can hear everything and that was
just that was real
that's real that's what these shows are
all about man
whoa you just heard a siren go
bombing down los cienega boulevard you
know
yep who knows what's happening
you can't buy that kind of excitement
and you wouldn't want to yep